- If watching "The Queen's Gambit"
has you looking to make
your next move in content,
you're in luck because we have five picks
that are sure to be a checkmate
on this week's Binge Guide.
The first season of "The
Queen's Gambit" has fans
and critics swooning over
its stylized storytelling
and compelling characters
that feel so real,
yet, stunningly, are all works of fiction.
So, if you can't decide
what move to make next,
we have put together
five titles that we think
are a part of a winning binge strategy,
starting with our
actor's spotlight "Emma."
"Queen's Gambit" star
Anya Taylor-Joy stars
in this British period
comedy-drama adaptation
of the Jane Austen novel of the same name
as Emma Woodhouse, a young
woman in 19th century England,
whose antics in matching
are simply delightful.
Fans of Taylor-Joy will
love seeing her show off
her lighter side after darker roles,
like in "The Witch" or "Split."
And while it might not
stick to the exact tone,
critics say Jane Austin
fan should still find
a solid match in "Emma"
and have praised it for
its modern approach,
energy, and unique adaptation.
"Emma" has a total run time
of two hours and five minutes,
which is basically a nice healthy break
between your marathon chess sessions.
Next up is our throwback pick
and that's going to "Mad Men,"
which debuted back in 2007.
This drama is about a high
profile ad agency in New York
in the 1960s, it's enigmatic
ad exec Don Draper,
and tons of drinking.
John Hamm picked up two
Golden Globes and an Emmy
for his breakout performance
playing said drinking executive Draper
across seven Certified Fresh seasons.
But it's the '60s ambiance,
brilliantly crafted characters,
and razor-sharp writing that
will have "Queen's" fans
feeling especially at home.
It'll take you about 79 hours
to binge the whole series,
which is just enough time
to master all the cocktails
while soaking in all that
great mid-century design.
Everything just seems so
much cooler back then.
Moving on to our brand new pick this week
and it's going to "The Great."
Starring Elle Fanning and Nicholas Hoult,
this genre-bending comedy-drama
follows Catherine the Great
on her rise to power
in 18th century Russia.
Now, the show features
delicious performances
and a wicked sense of humor,
and it was just renewed
for a second season,
so there's even more greatness on the way,
which is great for us.
And with just 10 episodes
at just under an hour each,
you can binge just one in
roughly eight and a half hours.
And for our Certified
Fresh pick this week,
we are jumping all the
way back to the '50s
to "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
Rachel Brosnahan stars
is Miriam 'Midge' Maisel,
a housewife who's
blissful life is uprooted
after she discovers her true
calling: standup comedy.
This award-winning Amazon Prime series
from "Gilmore Girls" creator
Amy Sherman-Palladino
has been recognized for its
ability to deliver warmth,
empowerment, and a whole lot of laughs,
and its ensemble cast of characters
offers something for everyone.
You can binge all three
seasons in just under 25 hours
and nobody will blame you if
you pick up some new jokes
along the way.
And finally, our
family-friendly pick this week
is going to "Queen of Katwe."
This Certified Fresh feel good chess drama
snuck into theaters in 2016
and with "Queen's Gambit"
reigniting interest
in checkerboard action,
we think that is worth revisiting.
Oscar winner Lupita
Nyong'o and David Oyelowo
star in this biographical
drama about Phiona Mutesi,
a struggling slum-bound Ugandian girl
who learns to play chess and uses a game
and her exceptional
skill to propel herself
all the way to the World Chess Olympiad.
Featuring uncommon smarts
and outstanding performances,
and with a total runtime of
just an hour and 24 minutes,
this one's a no-brainer for
people looking for a great film
on the shorter side or a
family-friendly alternative
to the more adult themes
on "Queen's Gambit."
All right, friends, well
hopefully this'll have you
saying checkmate on your
next few binge sessions.
Be sure to let us know what
you are currently streaming
in the comment section.
And don't forget to check back
here for more recommendations
based around the movies
and shows that you love
right here on the Rotten
Tomatoes Binge Guide.
(upbeat instrumental music)